team fakes are AI powered videos which
can make anyone appear to say or do
almost anything they're no longer The
Preserve of nerds or CGI experts freely
available apps can make videos like this
in minutes
hello peers Donald Trump here with a
very special announcement on uh
I'm officially endorsing Ron DeSantis to
be the next president of the United
States God Bless America hey Karen I
mean beers it's Kanye West here
reminding you that I'm not a shark just
a blowfish and that there's hope for you
too peers have a great show hello Piers
Elon Musk here talking to you from Tesla
headquarters I know you've wanted me on
your show for ages and sorry to
disappoint
it will happen soon I promise maybe on
the moon maybe on Mars but I promise
you'll see me soon
that's actually probably true
um it's just a bit of fun obviously but
it could not be couldn't it you can see
how that could be really quite dangerous